-You had your brother on stage,
which is great, and then,
of course, you also brought
Tommy on stage,
which was one of the great
moments of the Globes.
He very clearly wanted to speak.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm surprised he didn't go
for the award.
-I -- Yeah, I'm surprised.
Well, it's interesting.
This was -- You gave him
an interesting choice.
If given a microphone or an
award, what would he go for,
and he went for the thing
that would amplify his voice.
-Yeah.
-Were you not the least
surprised that
he tried to speak?
-No, I'm not surprised.
But, look, it's
a long time coming.
He kept saying to me --
'Cause like with Tommy,
what he does, you know, if any
other person did what he does,
it would just end
in pure disaster.
But he somehow always turns
disaster into something positive
and so here he is --
What I said,
there was, like, 19 years before
he had been, you know,
stuck in limo traffic that
was going to the Globes
and he was really upset
and it was one of the nights
that he actually turned
and was like, "You know what?
I'll show all them.
I'll make my own movie."
You know, and there he is,
19 years later on the stage.
-That's really insane.
-And, he kept saying to me
all night afterwards,
"It's destiny, James.
It's destiny."
-It's really weird when things
go right for crazy people
because then --
[ Laughter ]
Then they think they're like --
-Believe me.
Believe me.
Well, and that's one of
the magical things I loved about
this story is, it's an ironic
success slash tragedy where
his movie is still being watched
today 15 years later.
-Mm-hmm.
-On the other hand,
as a creative person,
usually the way --
One of the ways you learn is,
you try to do --
You're aiming for something,
you make some mistakes, and you
realize, "Oh, I didn't go where
I wanted to go, maybe
I should change some things."
He did that.
He's trying to make a drama on
the level of Tennessee Williams,
but he made a comedy, so that
became a success
and then he flipped the switch
and said I intend to do comedy,
so he'll never learn
from the mistakes he made.
-Right.
And I think it's probably not
a great sign that he hasn't --
Has he made a second film?
-Yeah, well, if you go
the screening.
He made this show
called "Neighbors,"
and he's trying to be funny.
We went and did a special
screening of "The Room"
for our film to play
during the credit.
It's supposed to start
at midnight.
It started at 2:30 A.M. because
he hocks his underwear,
it says Tommy Wiseau underwear,
his T.W., as he call them.
-Uh-huh.
-Right, he puts them on
people in the lobby and
they come model them on stage.
And then he shows, not one, but
every episode of "Neighbors."
-Oh, boy.
-Yeah.
So I fell asleep in that
screening of "The Room."
-You nailed "The Voice,"
and we were saying
when we were talking
about the film earlier --
People, when you first --
If you haven't seen "The Room"
when you see this character,
it's a very big swing from you,
but it is actually
incredibly accurate.
And you tried very hard
to get the voice right.
-Yeah.
-You had recordings of him?
-Right.
So, like I said, Tommy --
I have the recordings
right here.
Okay, Tommy flipped the switch
after he realized that people
were laughing at it and said,
I intended to be comedy.
So, I couldn't really --
So he had rewritten history,
so I couldn't really go
to him and ask him about
what he was like during
"The Room" because he'd just
give me, "Oh, well, I intended
this to be funny."
But he used to record
himself all the time.
He would drive around in his car
and talk to himself on
a mini tape recorder.
-Uh-huh.
This is, like, five years before
"The Room," 20 years ago.
His good friend Greg,
as good friends do,
stole some of these tapes
way back when.
And then, when I was going
to get ready for it,
he had digitized them
and he sent them to me
and they're incredible.
It's Tommy, you know,
complaining about
acting teachers
and you can see --
It was like I got his journal
but the audio book version and
so here's a little thing.
-Okay.
-This is him talking about
an acting teacher.
-[ Inaudible ]
That was okay, but again, I had
an argument with him as usual.
-Again, as usual.
As usual.
-This time was, he said,
"Why don't you do the same thing
in French."
It's so stupid.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what
his problem is.
I know what his problem is.
Because he knows
I'm very powerful.
He can feel it.
This power.
-You see that?
[ Applause ]
-He's been Tommy Wiseau
the whole time.
-Oh, yeah.
-He's been him the whole time.
Hey, congratulations
on the film.
Thank you for talking with me
about everything today
and I hope to see you soon.
All right.
James Franco, everybody.